ascolta in silenzio
no ascolta un contatto il silenzio è
facile da ascoltare il contatto ma cosa
assurda no pensare di ascoltarlo il
contatto qualcosa di tattile è un
qualcosa in cui noi pensiamo già che ci
siano un corpo vicino alla pelle che ci
sia a contatto con qualcosa e mettere
l'ascolto il contatto insieme ci sembra
un ossimoro
la prima cosa che ho pensato quando e
hanno invitato
e sono stati proprio i vari significati
di contatto e ho pensato uno speech è
molto semplice in cui andiamo a
rivederci i vari significati di contatto
il primo che mai avuto in mente è stato
il contatto fisico e del contatto fisico
il primo che mi è venuto in mente è
stato quello intimo quindi quel contatto
che c'è quando ad esempio no immaginate
quante intimo il contatto del bimbo che
cresce dentro la mamma a contatto no
forse il primo contatto che abbiamo il
primo contatto che alla mamma che
sfiorandosi la pancia sente il bimbo che
si muove quindi immaginate come questa
cosa entra nel nostro immaginario di
contratto
nella maggior parte dei casi il nostro
contatto diventa informale il contatto
informale quello che ogni famiglia
quello che è mancato
tante volte anche negli ultimi periodi è
quel contatto in cui di cui tutti
abbiamo sentito l'esigenza e che appena
usciti di casa abbiamo ricercato sapete
se non poter vedere se ci pensate bene
nell'ultimo anno
ovviamente non è banale dire che il
contatto c'è stato fermato limitato
ma se ci ragioniamo bene questo contatto
se non potevamo toccarci c'è stato
comunque oppure no quindi noi abbiamo
toccato qualcuno senza poterlo toccare e
siamo riusciti ad ascoltare il contatto
delle persone intorno
in questo speech non vi darò risposte ma
aggiunge ronghi
quindi questo è il mio lavoro di oggi è
stato votato formale
se ci pensate ci hanno detto come prima
cosa che il contatto formale a cui erano
abituati da anni cioè il darci una mano
la stretta di mano il patto no che c'è
con persone molte volte che sconosciute
ma in cui diciamo io ti saluto e
iniziamo a fidarci un pochino quello
dell'altro non si potrebbe fare ma il
contatto comunque si arriva tanto lo so
se ci pensate bene è stato sostituito
quindi non abbiamo più avuto la mano
abbiamo del gomito
quindi c'è sempre è sempre rimasto
qualcosa che ci potesse avvicinare avrà
un altro successivamente non pensate
anche avvicinare la mano a qualcun altro
il classico non la scossa elettrica che
passa quante volte è successo tra l'uno
e l'altro quindi la carica
elettrostatica che ci passiamo da un e
l'altro tanto che questa cosa con
l'amato linearmente al contatto
elettrico quindi e quante volte quanti
interruttori quest'anno abbiamo toccato
e abbiamo capito nel patto
quante cose tocchiamo tutti i giorni
quindi siamo diventati consapevoli di
quante cose tocchiamo noi toccano gli
altri mi sarebbe piaciuto tantissimo in
questo speech lasciarvi qualcosa con cui
voi potrete toccare tutto il tempo non
potevo farlo per quale ragione perché
l'evento la prima persona che lo avrebbe
passato alla seconda che avrebbe
guardato male alla terza che l'avrebbe
guardo ancora peggio ok e all'ultimo non
sarebbe mai arrivato
eccetto per il periodo in cui siamo e
questo mi sembra abbastanza chiaro da
capire l'energia è uno di quei contatti
che noi abbiamo di continuo di energia e
comunque quando mi chiamò da mano a
qualcuno immaginate la stretta di mano
la forza con cui viene stretta la mano
la temperatura mi viene stretta la mano
noi sentiamo il calore dell'altra
persona
andiamo a avere una trasmissione di
energia da una persona all'altra o
pensate quante cose dice la stretta di
mano quanto stretto c'è una dopo la mano
e poi senti alla temperatura del corpo
dell'altra persona per il nostro tempo
interviene ancora e ne serve una
trasmissione di energia se ci pensiamo
bene questa energia e se ci pensate in
generale l'energia è ciò che ci permette
anche di ricordare è ciò che ci crea le
emozioni nel nostro cervello abbiamo di
continuo energia quindi tutti i nostri
pensieri noi sappiamo benissimo grazie
alle neuroscienze che il cervello con a
cassetti in cui mette cose ma tante
parti i cui appunto i vari pensieri
vengono in qualche modo memorizzato
grazie a tante forze magnetiche
elettromagnetiche e via alla fine di
lettere che sembra sono sempre dei
contatti che viaggiano e che cosa
succede che quando pensiamo alla faccia
di una persona la prima cosa che si vede
che che succede nel nostro cervello è
che vengono recuperate da tante parti
del nostro cervello
tutte queste informazioni vengano messi
insieme per creare un'immagine quindi
noi abbiamo energia all'interno del
nostro cervello che entra in contatto
che ci crea cose il contatto visivo
in questo momento sto cercando di
mantenere il contatto visivo con voi non
vi vedono perché la luce faccia quindi
una luce energia che arriva dalla in
fondo ai miei occhi che non mi permetta
di vedervi perfettamente il contatto
visivo è molto importante ad esempio per
me che parlo ad esempio un contatto
perché io posso vedere come reagisce
come vi muovete cosa non cosa pensate ma
come vi state ponendo quello che io
e stato proprio no anche agli sguardi
pensate l'importanza degli sguardi il
contatto visivo è veramente pazzesco e
immaginate i due innamorati due persone
che si vedono per la prima volta due
persone che si vogliono conoscere
tramite uno sguardo non nel contatto
visivo
c'è un primo contatto e l'occhio
bellocchio sappiamo bene come vi
ricordate dalle scuole elementari quando
ci dicevano coni e bastoncelli e ci
dicevano che insomma la luce arriva e si
eccitano i nostri con i vostri uccelli e
noi a seconda di questa energia che
arriva dentro che ci tocca che ci sfiora
produciamo energia che arriva al
cervello e ci crea questa immagine è
forte come immaginatevi proprio in un
campo di sera di notte
immaginate come guardando il cielo
noi vediamo un pianeta vediamo le stelle
e che cos'è quella energia
no dico bene quindi è sempre un contatto
visivo e questa energia che c'è di mezzo
luce che arriva un pianeta no tramite il
sole che torna verso di noi e noi
riusciamo a vedere quindi immaginate il
punto viaggio fa questa energia e e
pronuncia immaginate proprio no quante
volte su un prato il contatto con
un'altra persona bellico infatti su
prato è e ricordate la guerra le stelle
[Musica]
vi lascio il mio contatto tra i 31 40
guadagnate questo lo lascio dopo il
tutto ciò che è astronomico immaginate
il contatto astronomico il contatto
astronomico e viene definito come
immaginate magari en eclissi
il contatto è il punto in cui il cono d
ombra che viene creato dal
dal pianeta davanti tocca questo cono
d'ombra tocca al pianeta che c'è dietro
esattamente dove c'è quell'arco provi ha
definito punto di contatto tra due
pianeti ma questi due pianeti non si
toccano in realtà no ma l'ombra di uno
la vediamo riflesso nell'altro
questo è molto interessante perché
nonostante non si tocchino viene mister
a tal punto di contatto
e a volte succede che nella vita se ci
pensate no persone che mettono in ombra
altre persone
nonostante non ci sia compatto non ci
potrà più essere contatto con quella
persona
e arriviamo velocemente dal contatto
comunicativo quindi è una delle volte in
cui io mi ritrovo di più nel contatto
quindi tutto ciò che è comunicazione no
al contatto che noi abbiamo di continuo
con le persone lanciato un sito internet
la zona contatti e una delle zone più
importante in un sito internet e luogo
in cui noi diciamo agli altri come
possono entrare in relazione con noi e
tante volte il modo con cui lo possono
fare
esprime tanto di noi no quindi spiega
esattamente come voi potete entrare in
comunicazione con me
pensate la voce io adesso sto
utilizzando la voce con voi
sono professionisti della voce ci sono
persone che con la voce si lavorano non
immaginate come la voce viva entrare in
contatto con le altre persone il cambio
di voce
immaginate notte saranno luciano
l'approccio e sly immaginate no una voce
ad esempio come può prendere il vostro
timpano e non fare nient'altro che
essere ingegnere mano praticamente no
cavolo una voce che riscalda immaginate
voi conoscete una persona nuova
e arriva che solare raggiante e poi
immaginate quando invece trovate una
persona che si è divertito tantissimo
negli ultimi dieci mesi è stata una cosa
più bella che ho fatto e quindi una voce
familiare a noi al nostro timpano lo
tocca e la noia è però c'è avete capito
certo è che se le voci che comunque
prendono e si recano un pochino non so
se vi siete mai
e se accordi globali qui c'è abbiamo
tante modalità con cui possiamo
utilizzare la voce
immaginate come a volte possiamo
tracciare con la voce no quindi abbiamo
bisogno proprio di prendere gli altri
coccolarli o ancora di più possiamo
accarezzarmi sradicarli se fare un sacco
di bosico la voce era sempre energia
energia che esce dalla bocca entrare
microfono passa da mixer vallecas non
che arriva al vostro vecchio e scelgo io
se coccolare vostro orecchio o fanno
altre cose che sto toccando in questo
modo è una cosa che succede in questo
tempo in cui non potevamo stare vicini
che ruolo hanno avuto gli strumenti gli
smartphone i telefoni hanno avuto un
ruolo molto importante perché era il
nostro modo per toccare gli altri e
senza poterci toccare estate quanti
costruiscono la voce fantino impostare
la voce esattamente per farvi sentire
quello che vogliono e noi sentiamo la
costruzione della voce ci accorgiamo se
una persona sta bleffando sta facendo un
qualcosa che per noi non è naturale
quindi noi riusciamo a percepire dalla
voce la naturalezza delle persone è una
questione di esercizio tante persone non
se ne accorgono di queste sentono la
professionalità ma non si accorgono dove
il limite di contatto di divisione tra
la naturalezza la serietà la
professionalità e la costruzione era
cosa molto difficile stare molto in
ascolto la trasmissione del contatto che
qualcosa che avviene come gli dicevo
prima
tante volte tramite energia ma una delle
cose che ti vorrei chiedere ed era uno
dei miei tubi perché noi andiamo alla
ricerca continua del contatto
siamo esseri umani siamo esseri sociali
abbiamo bisogno di contatto ci sono
attività bruttissima e mangiate il boss
finger lo scomparire totalmente da una
persona
non contava più non rispondere ai
messaggi non non avere più un contatto
che non è detto che sia fisico se ci
pensa a vedere è un altra forma di
contatto
ma è una violenza non compatto ma noi
sappiamo ascoltare in contatto
possiamo renderci conto di quel contatto
che non è contatto sappiamo capire
quando le persone si stanno dicendo cose
e stanno cercando di toccarci riusciamo
a farci toccare dalle cose che dicono le
persone
siamo ancora capaci di fare questa cosa
ma come si fa ascoltare il contatto
comizio prima io non vi darò risposte ma
vi voglio lasciare proprio con questi
dubbi cioè come si ascolta al contatto
forse nel significato delle parole forse
nella scelta che fanno le parole delle
persone delle parole che sta utilizzando
forse li idonei ci sono tante cose
dietro se c era giornate bene ci sono
esperti di dizione esperti della voce ma
le parole che vengono scelte tante volte
non ci insegnano a scuola
quali sono ma noi dobbiamo comunque
imparare a selezionarle e a utilizzarle
ascoltare il contratto caricata di
allenamento e è la cosa più difficile
che sono persone che faticano molto a
esprimere anche il loro contatto si sono
ricordati anno prima quando giocavo con
la voce ci sono persone che sono
continuamente arroganti nella voce ma in
realtà hanno bisogno di contatto che
stanno cercando entra in contatto ed è
molto faticoso per queste persone
io sono uno di quelli che tante volte ci
trovo da utilizzare nonostante lavori
con la voce mi trovo utilizzare toni
totalmente sbagliati ed è grave perché
non tanto che io lo sbagli che sa cosa
ovviamente
ma è grave anche che tante volte che c'è
dall'altra parte non puoi andare oltre
non sia disponibile a cercare dietro
quell atteggiamento e questo è sbagliato
e questo ovviamente non è per capire nei
miei confronti una cosa che anch'io
faccio di continuo con gli altri abbiamo
un pregiudizio per cui crediamo di aver
capito esattamente quello che sia stato
detto ma alla fine abbiamo collocato
tutto un pregiudizio della parola
utilizzata del tono utilizzato della
modalità utilizzata e c'è una ricerca di
contatto in realtà dietro
cosa rimane del contatto tutte le volte
che è veramente un tappo e gli uni con
gli altri
lasciamo comunque una parte di noi
dentro gli altri dei vari perché avete
visto oggi di certo qualcosa rimane
dentro ci sono dei ragionamenti che
partono ci sono delle dei frammenti che
rimangono dentro gli speaker di frasi
dette si sono ascoltati le emozioni che
sono partite quindi quell'energia che è
uscita dalla voce delle persone che
erano qua sopra
ha viaggiato è arrivata dentro i vostri
timpani che hanno coccolato che ha fatto
arrabbiare non avete capito cosa è
successo
voi lo avete capito la vede interpretato
alla fine in un qualche modo forse ha
imboccato ascoltate contatto grazie
[Applauso]